if somebody said hey it's all over this
is what you've done would you be proud
of what you've accomplished is it good
enough for you cool uh no it's not no
and I but I mean I'm proud of it but not
enough like I feel like there's more and
I think the main part is raising my my
my boys kind of like what you said I
feel like there's there's more to give
am I proud of what we accomplished like
with us on our show yeah I think it
stands up and our podcast that we do
together I'm like this is legit if my
kids watch that show that's great but
that's a TV show my thing that I think
about is how can I be an example for my
children is is much more important